devastadas varias familias taiwanesas se
reunieron en el lugar del accidente el
descarrilamiento de un tren la víspera
acerca de la ciudad costera de eeuu
alien whalen mató al menos a 51 personas
una catástrofe para el estado insular y
sus habitantes que ocurre en medio del
fin de semana anual de limpieza de
tumbas un momento de recogimiento en el
que los taiwaneses rinden homenaje a sus
familiares desaparecidos
la presidenta del territorio acudió
inmediatamente a la escena de la
tragedia
he venido hoy a hualien para visitar a
los heridos y expresar mis condolencias
a las familias de los pasajeros
fallecidos y kaupthing por supuesto les
ayudaremos en los próximos días
mientras tanto el equipo de rescate
sigue trabajando las autoridades temen
descubrir otras víctimas en el interior
de los vagones que están abarrotando la
pista pero el acceso está resultando muy
difícil para los rescatistas
encontramos que los cuerpos de las
víctimas del octavo coche estaban
apilados unos encima de
otros y el vagón estaba completamente
deformado los rescatistas no pudieron
llevar el material allí a tiempo si
existe un caos la investigación en curso
sugiere que fue una máquina de
construcción mal aparcada que se deshizo
y provocó el accidente justo cuando el
tren estaba a punto de entrar en el
túnel el conductor del vehículo
implicado ha sido puesto en libertad
bajo fianza y se le ha prohibido salir
del país